[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en Colombie les coureurs sont de
véritables stars des héros adulés dans
tout le pays
ce jour-là les championnats nationaux de
cyclisme sur route se déroulent devant
une foule enthousiaste mais en coulisses
à peine les coureurs ont franchi la
ligne d'arrivée qu'une équipe de
chaperon a cours il s'assure que les
sportifs ne se rendent pas aux toilettes
une obligation pour éviter que le
prélèvement urinaire ne soit contaminé
ou déclarés non conformes
la station c'est dans cette pièce qui
est effectuée le prélèvement soit
d'urine soit de sang
peut sortir et partir
malheureusement les contrôles antidopage
effectués lors des compétitions ne sont
pas les plus efficaces pour détecter
d'éventuelles tricheries certaines
substances sont indétectables si elles
ont été injectées avant le jour de la
course
c'est pourquoi l'organisation nationale
antidopage se concentre sur les
contrôles hors compétition
cette agence dispose de 30 médecins
répartis sur tout le territoire pour
débusquer les tricheurs
ce jour-là le docteur accosta va
réaliser un prélèvement urinaire au
domicile d'un coureur cycliste ces
contrôles sont toujours inopinés
[Musique]
une fois le prélèvement effectué les
échantillons vont entreprendre un long
voyage car en 2017 le laboratoire de
Bogota a été suspendu par l'Agence
mondiale antidopage à cause d'analyses
non conformes depuis tous les tests
antidopage sont transférés vers d'autres
laboratoires certifiés aux États-Unis au
Canada
c'est justement lors d'un test hors
compétition que ce cycliste a été
contrôlé positif il a accepté de
témoigner anonymement il accuse un
directeur sportif de l'avoir incité à se
doper avant une course en Colombie
[Applaudissements]
le cycliste s'injecte de l'EPO
l'héritropoïétine cette hormone favorise
la production de globules rouges ce qui
augmente l'apport en oxygène dans les
muscles
une façon artificielle d'améliorer sa
résistance à l'effort
s
le cycliste est contrôlé le résultat du
test antidopage est positif affolé il
contacte son directeur sportif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le coureur est alors interdit de
compétition suite à cette sanction il
tombe en dépression
se procurer des substances interdites en
Colombie seraient assez simple c'est en
tout cas ce qu'affirme Yoann robbayo il
est le seul en Colombie avoir été
sanctionné pour administration ou
tentative d'administration d'un produit
dopant un cycliste
devant notre caméra il nous assure que
le trafic de produits dopants fait
partie de son passé mais selon lui le
dopage est largement répandu dans le
milieu et comme moto
ça me fait de la peine de le dire mais
ça existe aussi en Espagne en France en
Italie partout dans le monde en
Argentine au Chili
même pas de contrôle antidopage c'est un
marché sauvage
c'est comme le darkotrafic tu aurais un
dealer 10 autres le remplace de janvier
à septembre 2022 cette cyclistes
colombiens ont été sanctionnés pour
dopage une condamnation qui ne signifie
pas forcément la fin d'une carrière
sportive c'est en tout cas ce qui espère
le cycliste que nous avons rencontré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]